[Music]
question comes from roseski and I saw
roseski was on the question is what are
the Abominations of Ezekiel 9 and Isaiah
chap 66:1
17 um I know in Ezekiel nine we kind of
did we allude to that one where well
anyway where it talks about the ceiling
of you know setting a mark on God's
people that cry out for the Abominations
that are done in the land and I will
read Isaiah 66:1 17 for reference
God to today in Jesus's name amen amen
the word of the Lord says they that
sanctify themselves and purify
themselves in the gardens behind one
tree in the midst eating swine's flesh
and the Abomination and the mouse shall
be consumed together sayth the Lord the
Abomination would refer to anything God
has forbidden as meat as as as food
whether it's a mouse an owl a snake it's
it's it the Abomination that appears in
the midst of a few words like the the
right or whatever else so Abomination
they would proberbly refer to forbidden
foods that God will not have the
Israelites eat if they'll obey him the
worst abomination in the Bible is
idolatry in other words something
replaces God that's the worst
abomination in the scriptures idolatry
which is the setting up of a different
God but in the passage you quoted based
upon the surrounding word Abomination
they refers anything that God has
forbidden as uh food based on that
context yes but the Chief abomination in
the scriptures is idolatry setting up
someone or something to take the place
of
God what Satan tried to do that's why he
was thrown out but there's several
Abominations in
scripture a man with a man is
abomination woman with woman Abomination
a human being with an animal that's
Abomination but Abomination one is
idolatry because it replaces God
completely indeed indeed and I think
that really that uh Abomination terms of
idolatry is really brought to light in
Ezekiel chapter 9 and I'll read verse
four for reference the Bible says and
the Lord said unto him go through the
midst of the city through the midst of
Jerusalem and set a mark upon the
foreheads of the men that sigh and that
cry for all the Abominations that be
done in the midst thereof and Ezekiel in
Ezekiel chapter 8 God just keeps showing
the the the prophet just Abomination
after abomination
order until at the very last we have
these was it like 24 like 20 or 25 men
with their faces toward the east and
their backs toward you know God so
perhaps that could be the ab well at the
end of the day that's idolatry so yes it
is I hope that helps answer your
question roseski